the biggest debate that we had
post-production was whether we were a
divided group about cutting that scene
out and half of us wanted it in and half
of us didn't and I was desperate to keep
that scene excuse me I'm so sorry I I
would love to stay in touch but I
already forgot your name oh it's Sarah
oh that's okay I'll just always remember
you as the woman I told to go [ __ ]
herself on Fifth Avenue how did you push
it through because uh I'm like a bull in
a china shop no I you know it's a matter
of genuinely justifying I was like this
is her one moment of being who she truly
is outwardly and I was like if this
movie was 20 minutes ago then that is a
piece of dialogue that would have been
in her head because she would be too
scared to ever say it out loud and for
the first time in her life she is saying
her inner dialogue out loud you have to
allow it at that moment I think that
people are empowered by their flaws and
I hope that people are empowered by
their past because we all have a messy
past all of us are wrinkled we're all a
little torn we all have history that's
beautiful and great that makes us who we
are today and let's live with it and
move past it and grow with it and all of
that so I do hope that people walk away